بالفعل ما زالت المعارك مستعره على جميع
المحاور لم تشهد المنطقه بهذا التقدم من
محاور مختلفه للقوات الروسيه نحن نتحدث عن
المناطق الجنوبيه حيث زبروجه كما اسلفت
تتقدم القوات الروسيه نحو مدينه اريحا في
مناطق زبرجيه التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني وكان بالامس اربعه كيلومترات
واليوم اصبحت حول سبعه الى ثمانيه كلمترات
يتقدم الجيش الروسي في هذا المحور كما ان
دانياتك وضواحيها همم مدينه باخ مت-
الاكثر اهميه المعارك في الشمال حيث قوات
باجنر يحاول الجيش الروسي او قوات بادنا
الخاصه توسيع الطوق يعني نعلم بان الطوق
على مدينه باخمه يشمل ثلاثه نواحي ال-
الناحيه الشماليه
والجنوبيه والشرقيه من الناحيه الجنوبيه
الغربيه بدات قوات بانر بعد سيطرتها على
اكلشيف كذا تذكر خالد اول امس تقدمت اليوم
نحو بلده تدعى ايفانكا هذه البلده تعتبر
في المحور الشمالي الغربي لان يعني الطوق
اصبح يكتمل اللي يتقدم من الناحيه الغربيه
تدريجيا همم ذلك لاحكام الطوق على القوات
الاوكرانيه التي ما زالت تقصف بالقطع
العسكريه الثقيله الروسيه باستمرار لا
توقف القصف طبعا هنا في قلب اذا كنا نسمع
الاصوات القسط متبادل تسقط القذائف
والصواريخ وايضا هنا قصف عنيف من قبل
القوات الروسيه على البلدات المتاخمه التي
يسيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني بالفعل هناك
محاور اخرى هذه المدينه المتاخمه يعني
الجيش الروسي قام قوسين او ادنى من اكمال
السيطره عليها بقيه الثلث الاخير من هذه
المدينه وهناك معارك ضاريه في اخر المدينه
يعني اشتباكات بالبنادق الخفيفه ما بين
القوات الروسيه والاكرانيه يعني فريق
العربيه كان في تلك المنطقه يعني حضر هذه
الاشتباكات بالفعل المعارك عنيفه وتشمل
مناطق
متفرقه في مقاطعه دانياس طبعا هناك
تباين ايضا ليس تباين ان العفو هناك هجمات
مرتده من قبل الجيش الاوكراني في محورين
محور افديتك ايضا المتاخم لمدينه دنيتك
ومحور همم على الطريق السريع بين
المقاطعات الثلاث خار كيف ولجانس
ودانياسكي تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه وبشكل
يومي التقدم والسيطره على عده بلدات نحو
الطريق السريع الذي يوصل الى قواعد تمركز
القوات العسكريه اذا تذكر ايضا خالد بعد
انسحابها من لمان لكن الدفاع الروسيه تؤكد
بانها تنحي اا مئات الجنود وعشرات اليات
في ذلك المحور بشكل يومي